- [Instructor] We're told
that Amanda read a report
saying that 49% of teachers
in the United States
were members of a labor union.
She wants to test whether this holds true
for teachers in her state,
so she is going to take a
random sample of these teachers
and see what percent of them
are members of a union.
Let P represent the proportion of teachers
in her state that are members of a union.
Write an appropriate set of hypotheses
for her significance test.
So, pause this video and
see if you can do that.
And let's do it together.
So, what we want to do
for this significance test
is set up a null hypothesis
and an alternative hypothesis.
Now, your null hypothesis
is the hypothesis that
hey, there's no news here,
it's what you would expect it to be
and so, if you read a report saying
that 49% of teachers in the United States
were members of labor unions,
well, then it would be reasonable to say
that the null hypothesis,
the no news here is
that the same percentage
of teachers in her state are
members of a labor union,
so that percentage, that proportion is P,
so this would be the null hypothesis,
that the proportion in her state
is also 49%
and now what would the alternative be?
Well, the alternative is that
the proportion in her state
is not 49%.
This is the thing that
hey, there'd be news here,
there'd be something
interesting to report,
there's something
different about her state.
And how would she use this?
Well, she would take a sample
of teachers in her state,
figure out the sample proportion,
figure out the probability of
getting that sample proportion
if we were to assume that
the null hypothesis is true.
If that probability is lower
than a threshold which she
should have said ahead of time,
her significance level,
then she would reject the null hypothesis
which would suggest the alternative.
But let's do another example here.
According to a very large poll in 2015,
about 90% of homes in California
has access to the internet.
Market researchers want to test
if that proportion is now higher,
so they take a random sample
of 1,000 homes in California
and find that 920 or 92% of homes sampled
have access to the internet.
Let P represent the proportion
of homes in California
that have access to the internet.
Write an appropriate set of hypotheses
for their significance test.
So, once again, pause this video
and see if you can figure it out.
So, once again, we want
to have a null hypothesis
and we want to have an
alternative hypotheses.
The null hypothesis is that
hey, there's no news here
and so, that would say that
it's kind of the status quo.
That the proportion of
people who have internet
is still the same as the last study.
It's still the same at 90%
or I could write 90%
or I could write 0.9 right over here.
Now, some of you might have been tempted
to put 92% there
but it's very important to realize
92% is the sample proportion,
that's the sample statistic.
When we're writing these hypotheses,
these are hypotheses
about the true parameter.
What is the true proportion
of homes in California
that now have the internet?
And so, this is about the true proportion.
And so, the alternative here
is that it's now greater than 90%
or I could say it's greater than 0.9,
I could have written 90%
or 0.9 here
and so, they really in this question
they wrote this to kind of distract you
to make you think maybe
I have to incorporate
this 92% somehow
and once again, how will
they use these hypotheses?
Well, they will take the sample
in which they got 92% of homes sampled
had access to the internet,
so this right over here
is my sample proportion
and then they're gonna figure out
well, what's the probability
of getting this sample proportion
for this sample size
if we were to assume
that the null hypothesis is true?
If this probability of getting
this is below thresholds,
below alpha, below our significance level,
then we'll reject the null hypothesis,
which would suggest the alternative.